oh
okay
i i looked at this once in my life
i remember when i was in fifth grade
there was like an after school maybe
fourth grade i think it was fourth grade
i was rated 1600
and i was at an after school chess
program
and then the chess instructor that came
was slightly
how to put this politely
a slightly eccentric person
who like for some reason we we were
going over a three-night checkmate
so but it was cool like uh
it was like a creative like mind-bending
exercise
because you can't mate with two nights
it's not the type of thing like to
really study as like a
a 1600
i was 10 years old at the time
but i remember like actually learning
some some idea that the trick is you
have to make a wall like the knights
want to be here
um taking away the squares and once you
make the wall it should be
[Music]
i mean i actually don't know how
difficult it's going to be after that
but let's see if i can figure it out
and
there is a the worry of the 50 move rule
too so
i do have to do this within 50 moves
oh thanks again kaboom
yeah take care
i'll definitely try to to pay it forward
in some way
but i really appreciate yeah all the the
support
i hope viewers appreciate it as well
okay so here we go
um
let's start with
start with this so this night this night
and this night can all kind of fill in
yeah we're chasing the knight this way
or chasing the king
uh
wait how do i
if i play this move it's already
stalemate
wow
this is a move that i would just play
kind of nonchalantly
i should be careful not to stalemate
uh let's play this move
sack of knight no stacking at night is
not a good strategy here
use my king first
wait my knights are in the wrong place
what do i do
try this
i have an idea okay i'm gonna maneuver
this way
hey it's not neemy
thanks for the raid
if you're just joining
i'm trying something really bizarre here
i'm trying to check me with three
nights and it's not easy
[Music]
um
let's play this move okay i'm preventing
king b5
allowing this
this is not pantala hare krishna this is
hari krishnan
different people
wait a minute okay so
oh this is so frustrating
i have to make the wall though
but it's a question
um
let's play this first
okay so i'm chasing the king i want to
chase the king to the bottom
i'm really close to making the wall
but how do i do this
i really thought it was gonna be simpler
there there
okay
i play this move
trying a different configuration
we're already approaching move 25 that's
not a good sign
i've created some superfluous knights
okay
i have this move
let's move chase as a king to the edge
so this is already some success
if i can get the king to the edge
now i can try and like just chase it
into the corner somehow
like this
maybe this first
that's not stalemate the king has this
move and then here
okay
i think i should play this
so i've created this wall
actually all these squares so the king
has to basically stay within these
squares
a question is how do i make
the
wall even smaller
maybe like this
okay controlling f2
he has to move back here
and then check
my meeting
wait
this is so mind-bending
check here
wait knight g3
is not stalemate because king here
knight g3
where does the other knight wanna go
king is misplaced
without knight g1 knight g1 the king
moves here
um i have this move too
i don't know if i'm missing anything
obvious
nights are so confusing
maybe this move
smooth
this move looks promising
so here it's mate
and then if king age of one and then
maybe i can dance around
king h1
it's so close
oh it's made in two
one
and then two
no that's not meat
that's almost neat
how do i do this
uh
chat check
i thought this was gonna be mate
did i have to create the wall
uh
[Music]
can you have four stalemate
maybe this move
no
i'm so baffled
okay let's give the king some breathing
room
maybe this move
that way i create um this wall
combined with my king so this knight has
room to maneuver
okay this shouldn't be too difficult i i
think i see the pattern now
yeah now this this knight can move
wherever
uh maybe here
yeah the king
the king is stuck within these squares
i have 15 moves left
15 more moves until 50 move rule
okay now i can move this knight wherever
i should just calculate the male at this
point
so the next move the king's gonna have
to move to one of these squares so if i
move right here
let's say king here king here
can go somewhere
and then
[Music]
i will move the knight here king goes
back
and then i'll get this knight here and
this knight here
okay
i should have maybe paid attention to
the tempo
so here yeah so this is made in three
one
and the reason why
two knights can't deliver mate
is you need like all the knights play a
role in the mate if you remove any which
knights
then force mate's not possible
uh like this knight is crucial to
control f1
this knight is crucial to
chase the king back into the corner
and this knight will deliver mate
okay
took 41 moves
i got confused
because nights are confusing